In an October 10 article in USA Today, Donald
Trump wrote that “If Democrats win control
of Congress this November, we will come dangerously
close to socialism in America.”
Are Americans embracing socialism?
In an August Fox News poll, 36 percent of
registered voters said it would be a good
thing for the US to move away from capitalism
and more toward socialism, while 51 percent
said it would be a bad thing.
The new question shows more support for moving
away from capitalism than three earlier identical
questions that Fox has asked since 2010.
This summer Gallup also asked people about
their views of socialism and 37 percent said
they had a positive view, while 58 percent
had a negative one.
In the September 2018 NBC News/Wall Street
Journal poll, 19 percent had a positive view
of socialism, 52 percent said they had a negative
view, and 26 percent a neutral one.
In all of these polls, Democrats were more
positive about socialism than Republicans
and young people more so than older ones.
Overall, though, Americans aren’t embracing
socialism.
Do you think socialism would work in America?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.